Andy when did you real I mean people
love your character on this series
when did you realize that uh this was
gonna be something special
oh look I mean when
pretty much when I first talked to Tony
about getting involved in it I mean he's
so he was so passionate about it I mean
I was such a massive fan of Rogue one it
was such a great film and you know take
having having had the opportunity to
have seen Star Wars from a particular
perspective
um on the dark side and then
and then and then actually when when I
was approached I was I was quite
trepidatious because I was thinking you
know there are so many snoke theories
over the years that I'd had to duck and
dive in avoid and kind of and then I
just thought oh no this is going to be
nightmare because people are going to
think keynote lawyers somehow associated
with with you know smoke and I'm gonna
have to talk around the houses and get
you know but but but but then when he he
explained to me what he was doing and
when uh you know and and the character
and
and and what of course with every single
character in Andor there is such depth
and humanity and they're flawed or their
you know and and the way that Cassian
weaves his way through this this
incredible heroic journey through you
know kind of
experiencing all of these extraordinary
characters but when but wait the way
Tony explained the the the the arc that
I was going to be involved in you know I
just instantly had an enormous respect
for I mean I've you know I've always
respected him as a writer director uh
but but just his Integrity in terms of
being authentic and knowing what he
wants to say and to use this platform
and to use this world and and universe
to say such important things about The
Human Condition uh it was it to me it's
it really just took me in and it's
exactly the sort of filmmaking or
storytelling that I like to be involved
in